technology is now giving us the chance
to go backwards and ask these questions
again what is the best ingredient for
achieving a certain function and now we
can produce it even if naturally it
doesn't occur in large quantities so
that's the possibility of what eggmented
is pursuing
just sit back
from the leaders of today
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
and now we're going to dive into the
world of food Tech with John wrathauser
the chief egg officer and co-founder of
augmented reality a co-chair also of the
naval alumni organization an advocate of
combining social impact with business
models that sustain and scale
thank you so much for taking the time
and you're working on something really
really cool that I don't know much about
but I know a little bit about the space
and so I'm excited to have a fun
informal but very formative conversation
with you
um about augmented reality which is one
of the coolest names by the way for for
startup especially especially in the uh
in the in the food Tech world and I love
the chief AG officer which you'll tell
me soon about uh and so John tell me a
little bit about yourself how did you
get into food Tech tell me a little bit
about your journey also in Israel and
and we'll get started
yeah
um so I'll start with the journey to
Israel yeah I've been I've been in
Israel about nine years and what first
brought me here was a sport I competed
for the Israeli National Lacrosse team
uh for a bunch of years I know a lot of
people don't even know that Israel has a
lacrosse team they only know lacrosse
from American Pie but uh yes we're
actually pretty good we finished seventh
in the world second in Europe
um so we're really proud of that that's
what got me here but lacrosse is a
pretty violent and aggressive Sport and
so it's not something you can play
forever I was smart enough to know that
at a young age and I looked around and I
found an MBA program here in Israel at
the tefmeon so that was my first year
here I competed for the Israeli National
Lacrosse team I studied for my MBA and
near the end of that I founded my first
company a digital Health company called
kihila I built that for the last eight
years but fast forward to today I'm the
CEO Chief egg off officer and a
co-founder of augmented reality like
anything worthwhile in Israel it started
with a disagreement
and so I was looking at a different
opportunity I disagreed with the person
needing that we went our separate ways
he went on to lead a different food tech
company and the incubator that was
supporting them fresh start in Northern
Israel they were creating a new Venture
called augmented reality he put my name
forward as someone who could should be
considered to lead the organization and
uh the rest is history
I love it okay and your own relationship
with with food just that I know the
context of the relationship with
augmented
yeah so I've been a consumer of food for
the last 32 years since the beginning uh
beyond that the food industry is new to
me um I've learned a lot I've learned
quickly and
um you know on the one hand it's a very
traditional uh industry but on the other
it's undergoing a lot of change today
and my one kind of deep and personal
connection I grew up in New Jersey my
grandmother grew up on a chicken farm in
near Central New Jersey Hillsboro New
Jersey and she would deliver eggs over
to Princeton University to Albert
Einstein and so my mom has made the
project of finding these old checks from
Albert Einstein to my grandmother and
her family found a news article about it
and so it's this really cool uh
connection where my grandmother used to
deliver you know eggs to one of the
smartest people and I would just wonder
what they would think today if they knew
we were making egg or egg like proteins
without the chicken you know the what
they would respond to that all right
well let's dive into it tell me a little
bit about the about augmented reality
what is it what is it all about what is
the really the the the the pain points
and opportunity that augmented reality
lives in I think that's a good place
yeah so the food industry is undergoing
a lot of change today consumers are
demanding clean vegan non-genetically
modified food and food products for food
manufacturers this is a big challenge
for them as they seek to move away from
animal Source proteins that they've
always used they're losing the
functionality that makes our food work
so these are the the functions of
gelling binding foaming things that keep
our cookies stuck together and and
things that make our cheese stretch as
we expect it to as we move away from
animal Source proteins we're losing that
and sixty percent of our dietary protein
today comes from animal sources so it's
not an easy fix
and so augmented reality is focus only
on protein functionality so we think
about the egg but not for the egg on
your breakfast plate more so for the
reasons that the food industry uses egg
its function we search for function them
using bioinformatics across protein
databases and once we identify protein
that we expect to give us better
functionality we'll produce that using
Precision fermentation or using
microorganisms that when you feed them
and make them happy they'll you know
produce protein for you so at a high
level that's what we're doing our first
product is an egg functional alternative
so I emphasize the functional because
we're not trying to recreate the egg
we're not trying to you know be a direct
replacement of methyl cellulose instead
we focus on the functionality we search
for it we're open-minded about where it
comes from and once we identify it we
produce it the egg and methyl cellulose
functional Market is a combined 41
billion dollar market but we're a
platform and so we'll repeat this search
and identify additional functionalities
and produce it
um across the growing 115 billion dollar
protein ingredients Market in the future
all right let's talk about
um perception the world changing
how and what how convicted are we that
that whether it's segmented and I hope
it's segmented especially for our
conversation but that this industry is
going to be turned upside down and and
how long do you think that'll happen
until we get there from a consumer
standpoint
yeah well
um it happening and and it's happening
relatively quickly uh really as we speak
I mean last week there was a major
approval by the uh U.S Food and Drug
Administration that approved uh one uh
company's cultured meat products so this
is the first cultured meat product to be
approved for consumption in the U.S
um Singapore is the only other place
that had allowed it so this was kind of
a major hurdle that the food Tech space
and cultivated meat in particular just
overcame that's not exactly what we do
Precision fermentation as a fermentation
is a very old technology
and there have been approved uh products
already uh in in the different markets
that we're interested in but there's a
huge need to make this transition
whether it's for environmental reasons
Animal Welfare reason because we want
more out of our food greater nutrition
better functionality and so on the one
hand this is problem solving and other
areas where this is really needed it has
to do with supply chain so we've seen
the effects of War we've seen the
effects of contamination so there's a
massive bird flu right now that's
affecting the the egg supply this is a
regular thing it happens all the time so
for various reasons we need Alternatives
and it's happening already
the final way that we think about this
at augmented reality is the opportunity
it's not just problem solving but what
would a chef a baker a food company do
what kind of products would they create
if they didn't have the limitations of
today's ingredients and so you know
think about your grandmother's cooking
and the food that we all grew up with
and we love the ingredients that she put
into it were they the best ingredients
or were they what was passed down to her
or what was convenient and in the
backyard technology is now giving us the
chance to go backwards and ask these
questions again what is the best
ingredient for achieving a certain
function and now we can produce it even
if naturally it doesn't occur in large
quantities so that's the possibility of
what eggmented is pursuing
interesting and so talk to me a little
bit about how where augmented is going
to be intercepting into the whole supply
chain of you know the food industry that
you're in so what what sort of the point
of intervention that you're taking and
how is that going to impact subsequently
the remaining steps
yeah so augmented reality is a B2B
ingredients company so you won't find
our product on your grocery store shelf
instead we're working with food
manufacturers to provide them the
ingredients that they're looking for
um and so on the one hand our customers
are very sophisticated and they're
looking for something very specific and
we have to deliver in terms of
performance but on the other hand we
don't have to worry about creating a
brand in the same way that a consumer
package goods company would have to
worry about that and so we're an enabler
both of the existing or traditional food
and beverage industry but also the next
generation of food tech companies so
many of these consumer oriented food
tech companies they are having
challenges meeting consumer demand
consumer expectations around what does
it mean to be a plant-based burger what
does it mean to be alternative Dairy and
so again this is is the challenge of
transitioning away from animal derived
protein we're losing that functionality
so augmented reality can give those
companies the old or the new companies
the functionality that's missing do it
in a way that aligns with all their
other goals you know getting rid of
animals from the supply chain or having
something that's more environmentally
friendly and ultimately deliver on the
expectations that their customers are
seeking
and so from your perspective is that
where's the market in terms of the
Readiness for you assuming that let's
say you had a you know the brilliant
product that is priced that perhaps is
price competitive or maybe maybe you
know it's it's okay it's not necessarily
price competitive where are you in terms
of the market yeah so number one the
company is very young we're established
in February of this year two months ago
we're imagining this is all about a
vision podcast yeah we're we're
sprinting forward we're really happy
with the progress and the stage we're at
um the the food manufacturers we speak
with are ready they've been looking they
haven't found uh what we're able to
deliver and so our challenge is is
giving them enough protein to work with
and and integrate into their products
today there's a general Challenge and
the Precision fermentation space which
is there isn't enough uh fermentation
capacity City globally and so this is
something we're working with Partners to
address
but to just to answer your question
directly people are looking for our
Solutions today we're speaking with them
about our next products there are other
functional needs that we haven't catered
to yet and so we're already in the
process of identifying our next products
and beginning to start Partnerships
around that
very very cool and so tell me a little
bit about it you know you as a c as a
CEO or sorry Chief AG officer and uh and
a little bit about your taking on
leadership you've held quite a few
interesting roles you're actively
involved with all sorts of communities
as a coach in Lacrosse I'm sure that
there's a lot of insights to be learned
there about leading a team especially in
a space that is where you values values
driven you have a phenomenal team uh
Elite for example I mean she sounds
incredible but tell me a little bit
about you know
how you perceive your own role as sort
of Chief egg officer here yeah so halit
and the rest of our team our two
co-founders Dr itemi
adidar dasi
um so everyone on our team is absolutely
outstanding I learned from them on a
daily basis I view my role as making
sure that they have what they need to to
execute they're the scientists they're
the ones making this happen
um I I'm an enabler within our company
to support them in in their challenges I
do have a science background a science
degree I'm definitely not the scientist
I know enough to follow the conversation
maybe ask a few questions but more
importantly one to hand it over to the
expert
um and so I definitely know my
limitations and I do my best to stay
within my Lane
um beyond that you know I'm a very
um
goal-oriented leader
um but I try not to take myself too
seriously at the same time hence my
title that's not the title that was
given to me when I took this role but I
had some fun with it and so
um you know I think we're doing our best
to enjoy uh our team our process it's an
absolute roller coaster you know highs
and lows like most startups and so
um I'm really fortunate to to be
building this with such incredible
people and we're having fun along the
way we're all super motivated by you
know the best things I would say trying
to feed a growing population healthy
food without destroying the environment
um and yet it's my job to really keep us
business oriented if we want to have
that impact then it's our job to make
sure that this is a really successful
Financial business so that we can
attract investors and scale this in a
way where we can reach more people and
have that impact at a larger scale so
that's something that I've learned from
my past experiences my digital Health
company before this I would say as a
first time entrepreneur on that perhaps
my mistake was
um you know being so problem oriented
and you know I I was obsessed with the
problem and I told that impact story
first and the business story second and
I think what I learned from that was to
lead with the business case and the
impact will follow I think of it as the
Trojan Horse right so be be accepted
because we are better less expensive
whatever our competitive Advantage is
and as a result of being accepted and
adopted we're going to have that impact
that we're all seeking so that was a key
learning for me from my past venture to
this one not really doing anything
differently other than What story do I
tell first I know our investors will be
our biggest cheerleaders as soon as we
uh convince them of the business and and
they're going to be the ones telling the
impact story
um so that that's something that I've
brought forward with me you mentioned my
experience with different lacrosse teams
Sports uh have been a huge My Life
um you know understanding it's a process
you can't show up to the game without
having done the practices that you
needed and expect a positive outcome
it's the hard work when no one's looking
it's doing the right thing every time
those are kind of the the values that
I've taken from my athletic career and
do my best to incorporate that into uh
this startup
I love it
vision of the company of what you're
doing in the world of what a success
would mean for a company like augmented
reality it's just such a fun name to say
augmented reality really is uh why what
would be a division from your
perspective yeah so
I think the vision would be that the
people that we the organizations that we
support that they achieve massive
success because of us right today they
have challenges with certain
functionalities their adoption is
challenged by that and so uh if we do a
really good job in delivering the
functionality that we're focused on
we're going to see it in the companies
that we support so really enabling these
other companies helping them achieve as
much success as possible that that's a
dream of ours and alongside that the
potential of this is what I call
designer proteins not not that they're
synthetic not that type of designer but
instead you know I think of a someone
sitting in front of a computer with some
levers and they say I want more gelling
but less foaming and so you tell us
exactly what you want we can tailor a
solution to your need and so that's what
we're working towards we're listening
closely to the needs of our food and
beverage manufacturing partners and
everyone has slightly different use case
and so the ability to tailor Solutions
around their use case I think that would
be an amazing thing to achieve
I love it and so if you're looking now
at
from a consumer standpoint what do you
need to achieve in order to
accomplish the Feats there from me as a
I guess as an egg eater or somebody
who's eating eggs and wants to enjoy you
know the final product that is driven as
a result of the engagement with your
product what do you need to achieve on
that front
yeah so I I think that our customers the
food and beverage manufacturers they're
the ones listening very closely to what
their customers and consumer is focused
on at the end of the day I would say
continue being you you know just pursue
the things that you're interested in uh
don't settle for something less so I
want eventually for myself to enjoy
eating a vegan only diet I eat
everything today but I I would love to
be able to you know have an alternative
to meat that was satisfying to me to
have an alternative to fish that was
satisfying to me and so you know it's
our job as food Tech entrepreneurs to
enable that future and I think the best
thing that the individual consumer can
do is try try these new options show the
food companies your interest and if it's
not meeting your expectations demand
more you know don't don't settle for
less but instead put the burden on these
food manufacturers to deliver to our
expectations and allow the food Tech
entrepreneurs through Tech organizations
to rise to the occasion
John thank you so much really wishing
you best of luck with augmented reality
sounds like an awesome Journey from an
awesome
standpoint and a great entrance and it
sounds like a lot of excitement vision
and um Clarity conviction over these uh
last few months so I'm gonna continue
following from the side and thank you
very much
thank you Michael appreciate it
[Music]